what is your idea to pitch to The
Experts and possibly win five thousand
dollars what I will be pitching is
Denver doll which is a realistic sex
doll company you get to rent the sex
doll you can choose the hair color the
hair style the lingerie color and then
we will set the doll up at a local hotel
which you choose from the list of hotels
on our website 15 minutes before your
reservation we attacked you the room
number with the room access information
now I would imagine your company uh
people are probably concerned about
cleanliness what do you do you clean out
all the dolls vaginas and the [__]
after I use it
what happened after I'm done with my
girl all right so the doll is cleaner
than any person with the cleaning
process it begins with an anti-microbial
soap the doll is clean inside and out
which kills 99.9 percent of germs
bacterias and pathogens secondly is
wounded with a UV sanitation like and
then it's inspected with a black light
to ensure that it's clean and then we
bag it and store it can I request a
virgin doll that has not been uh with
any man yet absolutely
it doesn't it does cost more but we do
have dogs that's never that hasn't been
used
let's go to our judges do any of the
judges have a question for this young
entrepreneur okay go ahead for Brian I
gotta I got a lot of [__] questions
for this guy let's do it dude what does
it cost to rent it price starts at 190
for two hours what does it do for you uh
it does a lot if you're playing with a
piece of rubber basically think of it if
you're married and your wife isn't
present or for whatever reason she just
can't have any um sexual relations then
what do you do you shouldn't go without
you can reserve one of these realistic
dolls and it's not cheating it's safe
it's clean there was a guy in Japan
didn't he marry one he did it was
usually a wedding that's right yeah just
because you got a real girl don't be a
big show it just doesn't make any sense
I'm sorry what is the grossest thing you
ever found inside of a doll did anybody
ever do anything horrible to one of the
dolls I think the craziest thing is a
guy put a blow dryer in one of the
doll's vaginas
um I guess try to warm it up but that is
it just melted
do any of our uh sex toy Tycoon judges
have any questions is it just the doll
or does it come with lubricants or you
know like a cocktail foreplay items
anything like that you can add a VR
headset so virtual reality to your
experience so you can watch your
favorite pornographic film and um it
does come with lubricants and condoms
yeah because you don't want to get her
pregnant no you know as a matter of fact
Brian told us a story that a one client
specifically requested a doll that had
not been clean and sanitized and Brian
did decline he didn't want any part of
that they have integrity let's go to
Susan Coleman first Susan do you give
him one two or three points three of
course being the highest which means
this is a great idea and you want him to
get the five thousand this is something
you'd even invest in possibly uh for me
it's one a one
really I know
it sounds like you work hard at it I
think that that is a huge question
Chad Braverman where do you go I started
very soft on this idea one uh there's
just something about the idea of a sex
doll being used by someone maybe
hundreds of people before me but I I've
moved to it chugged up only which is a
two uh I guess only because I'm thinking
of the idea a little bit almost like
it's very Japanese there's like love
hotels in Japan where like people go
they just rent the rooms for a half hour
so I'm thinking maybe there's something
here it's not something I would
personally invest in I have to say I
kind of agreed with Chad on this one
because it did start soft for me because
it was like and then once you explain
the concept and the different
possibilities and the fact that yes
maybe someone is lonely or there's
something your partner doesn't want to
try I get anal a lot where one partner
says absolutely not the other partner
says I have to have it so I'm giving you
a three a full bonus wow you're gonna
fulfill so many fantasies all right way
to go Ryan Dr Sunny with a three